Okay.
So I want to continue the story about cleaning up,
uh,
landscapes that had been severely affected.
And I wanted to use this as a basis for reviewing a variety of different laws
that apply in certain key provisions in the statutes,
uh,
that,
have met with more or less success.
And I'm going to start today with the National Environmental Policy Act,
which was passed in late 1969 and it was one of them,
the first statutes that declared a comprehensive national policy to protect the
environment.
And I wanted to just pause on this because many people think that the idea of
sustainability is fairly new.
But if you look at the purpose statement inside the statute,
you see that back in the late 1960s,
uh,
that many of the ideals that people now believe and think of when they use the
phrase sustainability are deeply embedded in the statute.
So let me just go through this quickly.
The congress recognizing the profound impact of man's activity on the
interrelations of all components of the natural environment,
particularly the profound influences of population growth,
high density,
urbanization,
industrial expansion,
resource exploitation.
And New and expanding technological advances and recognizing further the
critical importance of restoring and maintaining environmental quality to the
overall welfare and development.
A man declares that it is the continuing policy of the federal government in
cooperation with state and local governments and other concerned public and
private organizations to use all practicable means and measures including
financial and technical assistance in a manner calculated to foster and promote
the general welfare to create and maintain conditions under which man and nature
can exist in productive harmony and fulfill the social,
economic,
and other requirements of present and future generations of Americans.
This is a,
an exceptionally broad mission statement.
This law was passed,
uh,
not with any regulatory authority,
so it could not prevent human development,
uh,
but it demanded instead that any project,
private or federal,
uh,
that would receive public funds from the Federal Treasury,
Treasury,
uh,
would be required to declare exactly what the proposed development was and to
project out what the environmental effects might be in the future.
The statute was also curious,
and that it included something called a citizen suit provision,
so that environmental groups or other citizen watchdog groups could monitor
federal agencies.
They could look at their budget and think about what kinds of,
of,
uh,
development,
were being proposed by Congress,
a contained in authorization statutes are,
uh,
and then think down the road about,
how to,
uh,
make sure that those developments proceeded in a way,
that,
uh,
had a minimal impact on the environment.
So this was the origin of the idea of an environmental impact statement,
a model,
uh,
for declaring and,
and,
uh,
basically,
making public,
uh,
all proposals for new development.
And also it created a,
an enormous industry in the environmental sciences.
Uh,
an industry that really,
uh,
involved,
soil scientists,
uh,
atmospheric chemists,
a water quality experts,
uh,
that,
that all joined together to try to figure out exactly what the effects of new
development might be.
Now,
if you think about the scale of our economy and you think about,
uh,
the,
the federal budget,
you,
you realize that,
uh,
just this past week,
our president issued his proposed budget almost $3 trillion,
and that's an enormous amount of money being expended,
uh,
that would be put into projects,
developed by the Defense Department,
the Energy Department,
uh,
the Department of Transportation and highways.
Uh,
even the environmental protection agency when they issue a permit now to a new
sewage treatment plant or a new water supply facility,
that treatment plant must be reviewed in the context of an environmental impact
statement so that any expenditure of funds,
uh,
demands that this forward looking projection occur.
And it's always open to citizen's suit citizen contest,
uh,
through litigation.
And it's been very effective in altering new development.
Uh,
many dams had been stopped by this statute,
uh,
by judge's interpretation of it because of claims of insufficiency,
of the environmental impact statements.
Uh,
and so that a,
it also includes a very extensive public hearing process whereby drafts have to
be prepared,
they have to be taken to public hearing.
People have to have an opportunity to review the material so that they can
understand what might be happening in their backyard.
Uh,
and they,
they,
uh,
may also be very critical of the quality of science.
And this is not a laboratory science.
This is a science that,
that,
uh,
really is predictive in nature.
It's a probabilistic in,
in a sense.
So most environmental science,
uh,
that,
demands forecasting,
uh,
you should think about it as being probabilistic.
Uh,
which is why most,
uh,
programs and environmental studies have a requirement for taking statistics and,
and often probability.
So,
uh,
the scientists needed to look into the past and try to discern from previous
studies what was most likely to happen in the future.
And the only way that a project could be stopped would be that would be if,
if the impact statement were found to be insufficient,
to not fully have disclosed what the effects would be or to include a science
that really was poorly done,
uh,
that,
did not seem defensible.
So I'm going to move on,
uh,
to,
discuss several other statutes now.
Uh,
but one key point is that citizen's suit provisions have been built into a
variety of major environmental laws,
including the clean air act,
the clean water act,
a circular,
which is the super fund law,
the resource conservation and Recovery Act,
the cradle to grave statute that I mentioned the other day.
Uh,
the emergency planning and community right to know act,
which gives communities the,
uh,
the right to,
to know when chemicals are being released in their environments,
if those chemicals are recognized to be hazardous substances and the endangered
species act.
So basically this,
uh,
this opportunity for litigation,
has,
has really radically changed the way that new development,
uh,
and uses of the environment I've gone forward.
Now in this case and the case that we talked about on Tuesday,
uh,
hazardous site on VA case in Puerto Rico.
Uh,
this was a very important statute,
uh,
in that the,
the,
uh,
court case,
Romero,
Marcello v Weinberger or Weinberger v,
uh,
Romero Barcella,
was brought in part a because the navy had not developed an environmental impact
statement,
uh,
that,
projected out what the longterm effects might be of their continued bombing of
the island.
So this statute,
uh,
required,
it was interpreted by a judge in Puerto Rico to,
uh,
require the development of,
of a draft environmental impact statement,
which was prepared.
It's kind of curious because I wanted to find that draft environmental impact
statement.
I didn't know whether or not there might be projections of,
of a longterm damage or,
or perhaps a counting of,
of kinds of weapons that had been released.
So I looked for it.
And in mud library,
the former government documents library here,
uh,
we,
we had,
and we still have many environmental impact statements that,
uh,
you can request.
Unfortunately you can't wander through the aisles anymore because it's been
closed down.
Uh,
but the university is still maintains these,
these environmental impact statements that are actually quite interesting too to
browse through.
Well,
I couldn't find this impact statement.
And a then our,
uh,
our social science librarian,
put out a message,
uh,
on her email list and to asked if anybody in the nation might have a copy of
this.
And it turned out that one person on this list of all university libraries and
public libraries responded yes,
uh,
that he had collected all military draft environmental impact statements,
including this one.
So he's xeroxed it and Senate.
To me,
it turned out to be a gold mine in that it demonstrated a variety,
uh,
of,
of a historical action on part of the navy,
including diagrams such as this.
You see the bombing range up here on the upper left.
Uh,
but you also see in basically the same scale,
other maps that the,
the,
uh,
navy put together showing where their targets were showing also color codings of
these areas.
In this case,
concentric circles that,
uh,
had the,
the metric in the key member of bombs dropped or pounds of bombs dropped per
acre per year.
So this,
this proved to be really important to try to think through,
uh,
what was released when it was released,
and where it might've gone.
And one interesting thing is that you see that this side of the bay over here,
it looks like it was continually targeted.
Fact tanks were located at the top of the hills,
uh,
and they were clearly being targeted both by a bombers but also by artillery
shells.
Uh,
so gradually this area,
this part of the landscape was being flattened.
And by flattening the beach area at the end of that runway,
they basically created a trough or trough by which that lagoon could drain all
of the material that had collected,
uh,
into the bay.
It also,
and I looked at this,
uh,
air photograph maybe 30 or 40 times,
and it hadn't dawned on me that this little light patch right here,
uh,
seemed like it was just an open area sand.
But it,
it,
uh,
you can track it in Google earth and find that it reaches down gradually and
then fades into seagrass beds.
Uh,
but clearly it's evidence that material has flowed out of that area and kill the
vegetation on the floor of this bay.
The same thing happened on the other side and if you see these lines in the
diagram down here,
these lines depict the,
the bombing rude,
uh,
so that,
planes would take off from aircraft carriers.
They would fly up in this direction on the,
on the east side.
They'd circle around and come back and fly back this way and bomb in both
directions.
So three or four a firefighter planes would be doing this continually year after
year,
decade after decade,
millions of pounds after millions of pounds.
So that a,
they disclosed not just a pounds per acre per year,
but a total amount of munitions so that the estimate,
the estimate,
uh,
of a hundred and a hundred to 150 million pounds of ordinance,
is basically derived from information that was provided in the environmental
impact statement that would not otherwise have been put to get the made
available.
Since that time,
I've recognized also that,
that the navy has maintained a really tough and tight accounting system of,
of what they did.
And how would I know that?
Well,
by talking to people that were ordinance officers and you recall those,
uh,
large concrete bunkers,
couple hundred concrete bunkers up in the hills,
a loaded with different kinds of weapons while they were officers or enlisted
men that were responsible for the inventory in each,
the buildings.
I mean,
they want to know how many nuclear weapons they've gotten and where they are
at any point in time.
So they had kept their records very neatly.
Uh,
again,
this information was not included in the environmental impact statement,
but it provided a basis for,
for litigation.
So,
so that,
uh,
it,
this,
this type of a historical documentation is often very difficult to come by.
Another statute that,
uh,
has played an important role here and in many hazardous sites around the nation
is the resource conservation and Recovery Act of 1976,
which was designed to manage both hazardous and nonhazardous waste.
Uh,
and included the cradle to grave tracking system mean meaning that uh,
waste or hazardous chemicals from their time of creation,
their movement,
uh,
via a ship or by rail or by,
by a tanker truck,
uh,
and their ultimate disposal disposal had to be recorded.
So it was a,
a large scale national inventory system.
And the key to this system,
it's just like the endangered species act that I was talking about the other day
or the safe drinking water act.
Uh,
the,
the core of this system and its Achilles heel is really that the chemical has to
be listed as a hazardous substance to make its way onto the list.
So you can imagine that adding additional chemicals is something that a,
the chemical companies and,
and people that use,
uh,
basic chemicals don't really want to have happen because it increases their,
their accounting responsibilities and the reporting responsibilities to the
government.
Uh,
it included a,
a hazardous waste land disposal band.
And this is kind of interesting because there are about 300,000 community
landfills sprinkled around the nation.
Every town has a landfill.
They used to call them dumps.
Now they call them sanitary landfills,
which is an oxymoron,
a,
if anybody has any sense about what's happened there.
But,
uh,
for,
you know,
much of have a history,
people have taken everything,
uh,
and just,
a piled up in a landfill.
And then by about 1950,
they started covering it over with,
with soil.
I'm not thinking about where the material might go.
I remember when I was young going to,
uh,
our local dump,
we called it a with my dad and watching trucks pull up an oil trucks,
pull up and drain their tanks into the piles or refuse,
uh,
people that,
would,
would pull up that were,
we're a mechanical mechanics that worked on people's heating systems and they
would use solvents to take the grease off of the,
uh,
somebody oil burner and that grease would,
the grease and the solvent would then just be thrown into the dump.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
if you dug down beneath any of these sanitary landfills today,
you would find not just a solvent's and,
and residues of oil and fuel,
uh,
but you'd find many other chemicals has plastics and other products degrade,
just leaching into the soil and to underlying water.
So that preventing land disposal was a very significant provision back in 1984.
Also,
the underground storage tank program is located in,
in this statute,
and it requires an inventory and monitoring of,
of underground storage tanks.
And,
uh,
you know,
you can imagine that a underground storage tanks that contain gasoline or,
or other fuels or,
or oils,
uh,
sitting beneath the surface,
in a,
in a steel tank,
uh,
designed to last 40 years has contaminated many,
many sites.
Those gas stations that you see with the yellow ribbons around them,
they basically are regulated under this statute and they are a product of some
engineer who had the bright idea probably back around 1920 or 1930.
That a 40 year life cycle for a storage tank made out of steel was going to be
an okay thing.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
you know,
what's the life cycle of a storage,
uh,
barrel?
A 55 gallon drum for example.
Uh,
so this,
uh,
this,
design error has polluted groundwater and soil literally around the world and
used oils as well.
What happens to that oil that you,
your mechanic drains out of your car when you get your oil changed every 3000
miles?
Well,
it used to be just taken to the town landfill.
So this statute prevented that from happening.
So the case was like any other community that had done many of these landfills,
so to speak.
And it was a repository for a variety of hazardous chemicals.
So key Rick rock controversies that have emerged include,
uh,
the listing issue.
Uh,
you know,
what's hazardous mixed years if a waste is mixed with nonhazardous waste,
uh,
is it still hazardous?
This has been a debate that has been intensely litigated,
uh,
with the idea that a dilution is not the solution.
Uh,
the idea that motor oils,
some of them are exempted even though they're toxic.
Uh,
that's been the subject of a much litigation household wastes a also,
can they be mixed up with a more hazardous waste mining and oil production waste
had been excluded.
Uh,
and,
uh,
one interesting provision in this case is the corporate officials can be found
guilty of criminal behavior.
Uh,
so,
uh,
the standard of evidence for a criminal case is different than a civil case.
A civil action,
uh,
whereby,
a civil action would,
would be decided by a preponderance of the evidence means,
which means that it's more likely than not that a damage was induced.
Uh,
but,
uh,
a core,
a criminal case of demands,
a higher burden of proof,
meaning basically that,
uh,
it has to be demonstrated that the causal link exists,
beyond a reasonable doubt.
And Rick were also,
as I mentioned earlier,
contains a citizen suit provision.
So by 1986,
about 27,000 contaminated sites had been identified and as I mentioned the other
day,
now there are more than 3003 skews me,
300,000,
uh,
contaminated sites in the private sector and perhaps 50 to 100,000 in the public
sector.
The on other statute that is at play here,
he's the emergency planning and community right to know,
act,
uh,
that's contained in the Super Fund amendments of 1986.
Uh,
and this basically gave every community the right to know about chemicals that
are made by stored in,
are admitted from local businesses.
Uh,
so that uh,
this,
this evolved after many first responders,
a experienced toxic reactions to chemicals that were stored in buildings that
uh,
we're on fire.
So they went into a,
put the fire out and received intensive exposures and it created something
called the toxic release inventory.
Uh,
the toxic release inventory is,
is a,
uh,
a list of who releases what,
where and when,
and it has to be provided,
uh,
on an annual basis to the environmental protection agency,
but only if the chemical is put on the list and only if it's produced or present
in at a,
uh,
a level that exceeds a certain volume or,
or weight limit.
So the Sarah amendments a authorized the additional funds for national priority
list sites,
uh,
mandated public involvement,
provided permanent remedies to,
uh,
restore sites or to,
to,
uh,
basically pay for proven damages.
It also requires something known as best available technologies,
uh,
to clean up the site.
So a huge question in all these cases is a,
once a site is contaminated,
how,
how should it be restored?
What's the standard for restoration?
Is it prehuman?
Uh,
is it a certain risk based standard so that it's okay to have a little bit of
lead or a little bit of benzine in the,
in the soil or the groundwater or the trees.
So these are very difficult questions.
No site is cleaned up,
uh,
back to its pre polluted condition completely so that the remedies are always
detectable in,
in all of these cases [inaudible] state standards apply if they are more
stringent.
And this is an interesting provision because it's one of the few laws that
allows states to preempt federal standards.
So the Clean Air Act,
uh,
basically preempts Connecticut for example,
from having tougher standards then then the federal government to,
to,
uh,
you know,
admit chemicals to the air.
But,
uh,
unless,
we'll talk about this in a,
in a week or so,
uh,
unless,
Connecticut is out of compliance with the clean air act standards,
then we have to meet California standards,
which are the toughest in the nation.
So the idea of preemption not preventing a lower level of government from
passing a law that is more stringent than the federal level of government is
very desirable from the perspective of,
of the private sector.
Now why would that be?
Basically,
you'd want a kind of a common ground you'd want to,
you want to deal with,
with only a one set of regulations rather than worrying about,
you know,
moving your goods or your,
your material or whatever it is,
your service across state boundaries and having to negotiate a 50 different sets
of regulations.
So this is a really important statute statutory provision.
And that includes a citizen,
a supervisions litigation basically stalled out in [inaudible] and it stalled
out a superfund cleanups during much of the 1980s in 1990s predominantly because
of the citizen's suit provision.
It's an interesting thing,
so that,
uh,
potentially responsible parties would then sue the government claiming that they
really were not the primary responsible party or that they should pay only for
the proportion of,
of the material.
It was hazardous that was detected on the site.
So the superfund amendments in 1986,
uh,
prevented certain forms of litigation by PR,
potentially responsible parties or parties that EPA had declared to be
responsible.
And things sped up.
The vak story,
uh,
was also affected by,
these amendments in one way in that it created the agency for toxic substance
and disease registry.
That's quite a mouthful for a federal agency.
It sits inside the Centers for disease control based in Atlanta,
Georgia.
And this group,
how has the responsibility to respond to any community that petitions the
federal government,
uh,
arguing that,
that they have been damaged?
Either their property or their health has been damaged,
uh,
by federal actions,
that,
uh,
are,
are now declared to be superfund sites.
So it allows the citizens,
uh,
of the nation to,
to basically get expert scientific advice to,
uh,
to figure out what chemicals are released and how people might be exposed and
what the hazards are.
And this agency has played a really unusual role in that they,
they very,
very rarely in their history.
Now there are 23,
24 years old.
Uh,
they very rarely have found that there was a,
a,
a conclusive that there was conclusive evidence that,
uh,
the,
the wastes on a site,
uh,
that the,
hazardous materials are released,
proved,
produced a adverse health effects.
So in 2003,
they went down to VA case,
uh,
because one of the islanders petitioned the agency,
with this question and they went about their business looking for a whether or
not the contaminants in drinking water might be a problem.
And they concluded no,
the drinking water is okay.
The water comes from,
from a,
a national forest,
which is on the mainland Puerto Rico,
and it's actually pipe six miles underneath the,
the,
uh,
the bay to the island of VA case.
Or they also concluded that now that the navy had,
had left the island,
that the air quality was sufficient so that,
that,
uh,
that did not pose a significant threat to the community.
Uh,
they also concluded that that,
uh,
the,
the food that was grown on the island and the fish that were caught in the
coastal waters,
uh,
we're not,
contaminated at a level that poses a significant threat.
So they,
they,
uh,
virtually washed their hands of,
of,
uh,
this being a significant threat to human health.
And they dismissed all of the claims on the part of the,
uh,
VA case residents,
that,
who believed that,
uh,
the,
the navy's behavior in their contamination caused a whole array of different
kinds of adverse health effects.
Okay.
A lawsuit was filed on behalf of of 7,100 residents on the island in night in
2007,
uh,
that,
claim that the navy was responsible for,
for,
uh,
loss of,
of health.
And the government's response has been really quite interesting,
uh,
in,
in one respect,
they responded that,
uh,
well,
they,
they are protected by sovereign immunity.
Uh,
which basically is an argument that,
uh,
you know,
the,
the king is immune from any,
uh,
any litigation that,
the king,
uh,
it should not be held accountable for a past behavior.
Uh,
they also argued that,
uh,
bringing a class action lawsuit,
representing a large group of people like this,
but focusing in on a representative sample of that group so that you wouldn't
have to litigate and develop evidence for each individual among the 7,100.
They,
the Justice Department,
uh,
believe that,
that,
uh,
they should be handled case by case.
Now,
here's a community that is well,
well below the national poverty level are they had no resources to mount a case
like this.
So that,
that,
uh,
several law firms,
if he had picked this up and,
uh,
one in particular has been pursuing Sanchez versus versus the United States.
And,
uh,
you know,
by some mysterious coincidence,
uh,
there was a convergence a of this lecture,
and,
uh,
the lecture on Tuesday and the CNN documentary on VA case that was released this
week.
I'm going to play you a,
if this works,
I'm going to play you just one clip from this documentary.
Oh,
nearly 40 years ago,
July [inaudible] 70 I was 17 and a half.
You said holding hands or twice.
He's nearly blind and he's an oxygen tank.
He has Lou Gehrig's disease,
crippling back problems and sometimes it needs a wheelchair.
This is where we lived.
The I can catch [inaudible] says he's been sick ever since he was stationed on
the island.
During that period of time.
Did you ever think something is really wrong with this picture?
All the time because I get sick
sometimes.
I stopped bleeding automatically from my nose.
I said,
my God,
why am I lead?
I come back and maybe I'm vomiting.
I used to get diarrhea pains in my stomach all the time.
Uh,
headaches,
I mean tremendous value.
My region and used to get blurry.
So what was on there today?
This decorated former marine is the thong witness in a multibillion dollar,
more than 70,000 residents of is Caribbean island.
About 75% of the people here or who would you,
US government.
They said what the US military did here maintenance sick when nearly six decades
beginning right after World War Two the American Ireland never jacket was what
the name of the wall
and you get a picture of what was the light when they would,
when they would use this island as a training ground and he started the brace.
You could feel the ground,
the ground would,
you can never go to college.
You could feel it.
You're off the way.
It would rain and rain bombs and this will go on seven days a week.
The people need the truth to understand what has happened is their Johnny Jr if
the attorney and the law school,
one of the biggest problems we have is it we don't believe that the military has
bullied complaint with all the chemicals and agents that have the news on myself
after years of controversy and protests and they left the,
I can sign it in 2003 today,
much of the base is demolished.
And what's that largely overgrown?
It hasn't started some toxic
Dr job walk up
of sick cause he has of the navy's bombing range
or results from the longevity involving uh,
the shelling,
the stranger and uh,
many different compounds including lead and mercury and cadmium as well as from
retardants fuels.
And many of these would be some baby tensing
these images five years ago by University of Georgia scientists,
she'll omer bombing and surrounding water through loaded ordinary.
According to Uga Sciences,
many of those bombs.
Can you think you could corrode leaky out synergetic.
The Environmental Protection Agency in 2005 doesn't need it.
Park as of yet,
I feel good fun toxic site requiring the navy.
Does he get to clean up the navy?
Identify many thousands of unexploded initiative and instead of one the not
outrageous islanders fear more tenable,
we'll the relief the US government's response to the islanders lawsuit is to
claim the sovereign immunity that residents have no rights to sue the
government.
And the government offered disputes that enables activities under yes,
they Anders ill
Saturday it 2003 government study.
That sounds Noli.
So do you think
my phones
for
texting with these orders
is not one of the plaintiffs,
but what question deposition,
he testified with weapons.
If you found the islands included chemical insecticides,
the fleet of uranium navels and the agent all
short and
[inaudible],
the old man for the Chrysler,
the military has acknowledged delete
and it's fun at Vf,
this American term,
Hey,
how do you do some big 10 year old back yard and you you've hurt someone
and you help them and if not we'll make it.
All right now as you reflect on that,
he should be asking yourself a whole bunch of questions.
One of them would be,
here's a gentleman who is now a mid fifties he obviously has many different
medical,
but he faces a serious burden of proof of exposure to chemicals that were
released by the navy.
So how would you think that through?
How would you,
how would you make that connection?
One question you might ask is,
were the chemicals that they described in the lawsuit that were released by the
navy present in his body?
Well,
you know,
the,
the historical reconstruction problem that I mentioned on Tuesday is,
is extraordinary.
It's incredibly complex,
scientifically,
and it will be very expensive to document how long do these chemicals last in
somebody's body?
What are plausible alternative sources of exposure?
You know,
the Navy,
the navy argued that heavy metals used in the weapons were also minerals that
had,
had been driven by winds from Sahara and dust storms across the Pacific and rain
down.
And perhaps that's a route of exposure.
So the navy has been very good along with the justice department in developing
these plausible alternative hypotheses.
Another,
Ben has another,
has been the ritualistic use of mercury.
Did the mercury come from a navy switches and the bombs that leaked out on that,
on that site made its way into the marine food chain built up and then made its
way to the dinner table and into people's bodies?
Uh,
or did it come from an electric plant that was located on the island?
Or could it have come from any fish and efficient in the area?
Uh,
when the agency for toxic substances and disease registry did their fish sample,
uh,
they wandered around the island,
sampling fish from many different locations.
But as I mentioned,
often the sample sizes were incredibly small,
less than 10 in size.
So what you want to do is you'd want to know that these chemicals had moved,
uh,
in a gradient from their location of,
of a release,
uh,
further and further away.
And you hope to find a,
a declining gradient in the concentration as you move further and further away.
But they didn't,
they didn't conduct this kind of work.
James Porter,
who is a professor at the University of Georgia that I mentioned has done that
work.
And as you move further and further away from the bombed area,
you do see these declines.
So key questions that are raised by this video.
What was the prior knowledge of the Defense Department?
I know that the Defense Department had very accurate records of the ordinance
that was released and where it was released and when it was released.
Another key question is,
should this move forward as a class action lawsuit?
If it,
if,
uh,
the,
the courts find that,
uh,
it,
it cannot,
that it has to be,
uh,
judged individually person by person.
There's no help that this would be a concluded in the next 50 years.
The idea of sovereign immunity,
uh,
should the United States be responsible.
And,
uh,
this has spoken to quite clearly,
in the variety of environmental statutes that,
that,
uh,
I described to you,
just 15 minutes ago.
Uh,
but so the central core question here is one of causation.
Did these chemicals caused those illnesses?
What's the matchup between the chemicals released the chemicals found in
people's bodies and what we know medically about the effects of those chemicals?
This is very difficult science to be held to a standard of scientific proof,
say 99% confidence that that,
uh,
there is this established cause and effect relationship,
would,
uh,
virtually make it impossible for this community,
to,
uh,
recover damages,
beyond a reasonable doubt said a different different matter.
Uh,
so what you see here as you see the,
uh,
the media getting behind this case,
being sympathetic,
uh,
having a very clear story about a chemical release,
not really knowing where it went,
uh,
not really fully understanding what people's exposures were,
how they might've been exposed by air or water or food.
Uh,
but you also have a community that has lived in an environment that socially has
been seriously affected.
There is no debate about the fact that the presence of the military,
uh,
put the economy of that island in the freezer for much of the 20th century and
the impact of that in,
in diminishing their income,
diminishing their access to basic public services and such as education and
health fair health,
health care,
uh,
such as early detection,
having to travel off the island when you don't own a car,
uh,
to a hospital on the mainland to Puerto Rico,
is a big disincentive to get early medical care.
Uh,
so late medical care,
uh,
translates into a higher incidence of disease,
and detection when the illness has progressed to become more serious,
cause more difficult to,
to manage.
Uh,
also,
uh,
everyone is thinking about,
okay,
what is the cost going to be?
What's a likely cost for this one site?
And remember the figure that I showed you the other day,
that,
uh,
the congress allocates a roughly a two to two,
two and a half billion dollars per year for the entire superfund program,
whereas plausibly,
uh,
it could take up to a billion dollars to clean this area and also to,
to,
uh,
provide sufficient medical care for the community.
And also remember the fact that many of these families had,
uh,
earlier generations that were plucked up off their property and moved.
How would you think about compensating them for their loss of property value
given $25 in 1945 for a track of land,
uh,
or for a,
the costs incurred by having your house,
uh,
bulldozed and in,
in having the family moved to a different part of the island.
It's also raises a very interesting counterpoint to the,
the uh,
uh,
Marshall Islands case that we saw the other,
the other week.
And that is that a,
when the United States decided to take over in the Marshall Islands,
they did so thinking,
uh,
that,
no one could survive an attack there.
They had to move everybody out of the islands that they bond in this case,
they believe that they could conduct their,
their weapons testing,
uh,
in a way that,
that,
uh,
would not harm the,
the,
the population if they concentrated them in the center of the island and they
bombed the end of the island.
But they weren't thinking ecologically about pathways.
They weren't thinking about diet,
they weren't thinking about airborne dust and prevailing winds.
So that,
uh,
the,
the idea that they should move the entire population off the island was
reconsidered.
Uh,
there are now available documents,
uh,
demonstrating that,
that John Kennedy a thought very,
very carefully about this.
And Kennedy,
uh,
you remember was president during the,
the,
uh,
Cuban invasion and a VA case was a very important base for,
for staging for the invasion of,
uh,
the Bay of pigs.
And what,
what,
uh,
Kennedy was thinking about was,
okay,
uh,
why don't we completely remove the island islanders and resettle them in other
parts of the Caribbean.
He decided against that move.
Uh,
but,
uh,
that decision,
perhaps as a come back to haunt the government and certainly is haunting the,
uh,
the islanders.
Uh,
however,
this whole mess is a product of misunderstanding,
uh,
basic ecological principles,
as well as,
uh,
a,
I think a,
a disregard for,
for,
uh,
the longterm health of the community.
There are a couple of other statutes here that,
that are at play.
And,
and I wanted to raise your,
uh,
bring your attention to the wilderness act of 1964.
And this statute is,
is quite,
uh,
interesting,
in that,
uh,
it,
it defines wildernesses,
uh,
an area in contrast with those areas where man and his own works dominate the
landscape is hereby recognized as an area where the earth in its community of
life or untrammeled by man,
where man himself is visitor who does not remain.
It goes on to define characteristics of,
of,
uh,
an area that,
I would have to be met before it could be designated as wilderness.
Uh,
but at the same time that the government left VA case and transferred
jurisdiction to the fish and wildlife service to create a u s fish and wildlife
refuge on the island,
uh,
Congress decided that it was also going to declare the area of federal
wilderness.
So it is distinctive in the United States right now because it is the only super
fund site,
you know,
reserved for the most hazardous sites in the nation.
Uh,
that is also declared to be a wilderness area.
A paradox that,
uh,
maybe you could explain to me,
especially looking at,
uh,
at the site,
the,
the government clearly thought that that,
uh,
it would give them greater power to exclude people,
which they think they're doing well by posting signs on the beach.
Uh,
this is a sign that,
uh,
is,
right on the edge of the water that,
that,
uh,
is within perhaps a hundred yards of,
of tank sitting on a hillside that became the target,
uh,
for,
for planes as well as artillery shells.
So the idea that that,
uh,
you could post a sign and it would keep people out.
Uh,
I,
well,
I took a research crew out there,
uh,
several years ago and,
on one afternoon there were six or eight large pleasure boats all lined up about
50 yards from this sign.
Uh,
kids are out swimming in the water,
playing on the beach.
Uh,
so that the idea that you would,
you could control people via,
via signs with no other presence,
uh,
is,
is a defies explanation.
Another statute that's a play here is the endangered species act.
And the purposes of this statute passed in 1973 are to provide a means whereby
the ecosystems upon which endangered species and threatened species depend maybe
conserved to provide a program for the conservation,
uh,
for their conservation.
So,
uh,
certain types of acts including,
damaging the habitat of an endangered species or taking an endangered species,
either shooting it,
uh,
by,
by killing an endangered species.
You are taking it under this statute.
Uh,
so,
uh,
this,
this law again pass back in 1973 a and the u s left the Ireland in 2003.
There were three decades,
uh,
during which species declared to be rare or endangered.
Uh,
particularly the turtles that lived on the island,
uh,
were clearly being affected by military,
behavior and maneuvers.
So here's a list of the species of any of you,
uh,
happen to be particularly interested.
So
I'm going to have to scoot ahead here so we can keep moving.
Moving on.
But I want to do to recognize that,
that this history,
this history of military action,
uh,
of,
of training,
uh,
basically testing weapons,
of staging maneuvers that preceded major military actions.
Uh,
it's created a legacy of severely contaminated sites around the nation.
Here's Johnston Atoll,
uh,
which is now the Pacific islands national wildlife refuge.
So you see that there actually is a pattern of taking a former former highly
contaminated military base,
translating it or transferring its jurisdiction into efficient wildlife refuge.
Uh,
this may look like the Moonscape,
but this is the atomic testing site in Nevada where you can see the craters
that,
uh,
are the result of,
of hundreds of other,
uh,
above ground tests.
Here's another highly contaminated sight in Hanford,
Washington.
Uh,
the Hanford works,
uh,
the side of the green run that you could read a about and,
and,
uh,
green intelligence,
the underground storage tanks,
the same problem that I mentioned earlier in the lecture,
a leaking radioactive waste that is,
is highly concentrated into the Columbia River.
The Columbia River is a,
a,
uh,
habitat for Pacific Salmon.
Uh,
and many other,
uh,
species of fish.
And it's a very,
very highly prized region.
Uh,
the military reservation on Cape Cod provides one more example.
This reservation has a history that span just about the same amount of time as
VA case.
Uh,
from about 1942,
uh,
just about a year of 2000,
2001,
actually,
the jets that,
uh,
were poor trying to catch up to,
the,
the September 11th,
2001 hijackers,
uh,
they were scuttled from,
the Massachusetts military reservation on Cape Cod.
Uh,
this site,
uh,
is sitting on go sands and gravels,
and it's basically a,
a,
uh,
a collection of very large aquifers on Cape Cod,
a in which the freshwater sits on top of,
of a underlying saltwater.
And the closer you get to the ocean,
uh,
so that anything put on the surface will drain into underlying,
sands and aquifers moving very quickly.
Uh,
so this has become the largest,
uh,
drinking water contamination site and remediation site in,
in the United States.
Now they drilled some,
uh,
8,000 different wells to try to figure out where the fuels,
the flame retardants,
the munition residues,
the TNT and RDX,
et Cetera,
or where did it go?
And they've monitored it out.
And they created these plumes that pump the water up out of that Aquifer,
entering into these charcoal,
uh,
tanks,
activated carbon tanks that,
uh,
some of which are bigger than this entire lecture hall.
Uh,
so,
uh,
you know,
day after day,
24 hours a day,
a decade for decade,
this water is pumping through their,
uh,
hoping that it will be cleaned up,
to meet the safe drinking water act standards.
By the year 2035,
3000 pounds of solvents had been removed from that water.
1000 pounds of fuels removed from the groundwater in eight plumes are now
undergoing treatment and remediation.
Uh,
this is immediately adjacent to a variety of cranberry bogs.
so cranberry farmers bore the brunt of economic loss,
uh,
when this was discovered.
So critical lessons here about VA case knowledge is power that's very clear.
Uh,
classified information,
uh,
prevents the public from understanding what was done when and where,
what the nature of surrounding or nearby community threats might be.
A question of who conducts the science.
Uh,
it's clear that the ATS,
Dr within the Centers for Disease Control,
uh,
was,
not doing high quality science and,
and,
uh,
came to a premature conclusion of safety.
Uh,
based upon the highly limited sampling.
A science normally proves no causal relation.
Uh,
so this type of science is perhaps,
uh,
one of the more complex that a,
I could imagine.
Uh,
also one lesson here that is,
is,
uh,
a parent is that new evidence of risky behavior.
A defendant generates a very defensive attitude on the part of government.
Uh,
so any information that they release a,
any studies that they conduct,
uh,
could increase their liability.
Uh,
so often the,
the,
uh,
the response is,
well,
then let's just not study it.
Okay,
I'm going to pause there and just wish you a great weekend.